you not only have done wrestling on
YouTube now you've uh branched down too
much as well and it's really cool
hearing you kind of talk about this like
are you two years ago or a year and a
half ago yeah yeah yeah with a call and
you were like God I'm really excited
about this merch stuff and I was like
dude it sounds sick you tell me about
you building like a whole world around
it I was like that's man we just put
I'll put a logo on stuff well I mean
like I did that as well before
um but yeah I so like with the merch
stuff like I'd have to give like a lot
of credit to otaku versus who kind of
like he sort of talks me because I
basically like I wanted to do merch
stuff and I was like I don't know what
the [__] to do you know yeah and I got
talking to him and like hearing like his
like explanation of everything and like
what it kind of was it really
um it really opens me up to it's like
man okay so I basically like I think
like a lot of people when I was like
younger I had this like story or like I
wanted to make and at different times it
was like a comic book a series of videos
a video game and I was like okay yeah
you know I wanna I wanna do this thing
and
um then eventually I was like okay what
am I gonna do with this where it's like
what if I made like a fake anime and
pretend that it was real and made much
out of that and it pretty much just
started from there um
yeah yeah that there's been other stuff
like gorillas is kind of similar-ish you
know and so like I don't want to take
like credit for that necessarily but um
and like I was working on it and then
like I was I just explained it to one of
my friends Rebecca brobeck's on Twitter
and she was like yeah I'll give you a
hand with that and she started doing
concept art for it and like the day I
sent her the descriptions for the
characters and she sent me back the
concept for the characters I was just
like oh [__] like this could actually be
so legit and it was it was so fun to
work on yeah and like it's done well and
people are into it and like you know
financially it's been like viable which
is great and all that kind of stuff but
I think it's actually something that
really kind of
it made me kind of fall back in love
with like content creation and doing
stuff like that because it added this
whole other thing to it and it's been
really really fun and like right now I'm
working on the third run of it which is
like everyone is like a new arc in this
fake anime and this is like the arc or
like the villain gets introduced and
like I'm so [__] hell you know I I
never know how I was gonna go but like I
I I've been so excited about it so to
explain your Concept in case you guys
aren't familiar you kind of like telling
a story through your merch yeah right
that's so cool built an entire world
around it with characters how long okay
I got asked how long did it take you
from like you said you had an idea of
like stories you wanted to tell how long
did it take you to actually flesh out a
world and a story that you wanted to
tell so from the point where like I
started doing it I think to like the
point where it's like it actually we
have a t-shirt design I think that was
about nine months and like a lot of we
basically every with the runs we do like
a kind of um we do like a little Zine of
all the concept work and all the [__]
that never even makes it into the actual
merch you know like the kind of
supplementary characters and like the
world and how it all works and
um so we basically just spent like nine
months building all that stuff up like
whenever I do it whenever I think up a
new character or something like that I
write down who the character is what
their place in the story is and then
their relationship to every other
character right and that's all [__] that
like that's never gonna make it into a
t-shirt or sometimes it does in weird
ways but it's the kind of thing where
like
I always feel like when you're watching
a show you can always get a sense for
when someone has thought about like
every part of this world and when
someone is like
kind of making it up as they go along
and I really wanted to feel like the
former Yeah because sometimes you know
you it's that's why I like World
building because sometimes you watch a
show and it feels like the world is
built around this one character and the
ones the stories I feel are truly
magical is when this is when you know
you turn off the episode or you close
the book and you feel like the world is
still taking place the story is still
continuing on right yeah yes it's still
continuing on even if you're like you're
you are not actively taking apart in it
um and the fact that you've just put
that into your merch is like insane well
I think it's like it's that kind of
thing earlier where I was saying like
having like a lot of interests really
can feed into different things in
different ways because like one of the
biggest Inspirations from it was um the
York New City Arc from Hunter Hunter
which is just this [__] insane just
like chain reactions of events yeah to
the point you get to the end of it it's
like what happens and it's like
I don't [__] know
and like it's so chaotic and insane and
it has like insane anti-climaxes and
everything yeah but because Takashi has
like thought of that these characters so
much it all works and it's so compelling
and I love that idea you know and I was
like I want to make a t-shirt there you
know yeah like that's kind of like what
some of my favorite moments like one
piece isn't like the actual Arc it's
when like the arc ends and then it like
kind of like you you get a hint about
what else has been going on in the world
I mean while right yeah yeah meanwhile
and then you realize holy [__] people
are fighting [__] Wars and Luffy is
just like chilling on this island one
particular part and it's when I think
they get back from the sky islands right
and it just there's like an episode or
two which is just all the chain
reactions that have been happening and
oh I remember seeing that for the first
time being like oh [__] this is insane
you know for sure it's it's it's like
you know you kind of realize oh maybe
Luffy isn't the main character for like
a moment right yeah yeah yeah that's
like one piece is like [__] 30 main
characters and uh everyone's just like
doing their own things that's just
that's just what I love about one piece
I guess absolutely so whenever you guys
mention me on this podcast yeah I get
a flood of messages
it's always interesting because and I
remember one of the ones Grant was your
story about someone Miss thinking we're
the same person or thinking one of my
videos was your videos and you getting
into it like and arguments on that
behalf but um I always think it's really
funny when that happens and there was
one story I had that I just loved and I
think I might have told you guys this
before right
um but it was a guy uh magfest and you
just it was just a regular meet and
greet and you know he'd been killing her
for like an hour or something and then
he's like um
I really loved your videos on Legend of
the galactic heroes did I tell you this
I remember this time
did I tell you Connor okay so
um I'm like oh
I don't think that was me and he's real
adamant he's like no no it was and I was
like I it's not because I've never
watched that show I'm sure and so like
I'm doubling there and he's doubling
down and but then I say that and I just
see him like collapse and he's like oh
no oh no no no and like that's what he
starts saying like he's really I'm like
who it's not a big deal like who cares
you know
um and then he's like I'm so sorry and I
have to be like no me it's all right
it's fine it's fine like it it really it
doesn't matter you know and So
eventually he recovers and he just goes
okay
I just want to say
I really love your what's in an OP
series
which is also not for you no that that
is uh that is just two mother's basement
another yeah
um and so I'm just I'm just standing
there and I I just I just go
thanks man
my favorite part of the whole thing is
later on he spots me at the con and he's
like he brings his friend over and he's
like this is the guy I'm like hey Jeff
too
nice to meet you
have you guys ever had stuff like that
oh all the time every other day so
um me and Joey get like people like
confuse us all the [__] time really
yeah so many times in fact it uh like it
most recently happens at uh Gamescom
when I was filming uh an official video
for uh like a new verse game
um the guy running the booth comes up to
me and goes oh yeah you are working with
us today I'm like yeah I was like oh I
love your stuff the anime man
that sounds like such an unnatural way
too I love you full screen yes I was
like oh are you are you the enemy man
are you here to work with us and I'm
just like ah I'm not the anime man but I
am here to work with you yeah my other
favorite one with uh gone and I was uh
in Singapore uh AFA which is like back
in like 2017 or something and I I was
guessing there and because you know gone
at the time was still living in Thailand
he was like oh yeah I'll pop over and
you know come hang out with you guys so
gone now we're just walking around uh at
the convention this dude far off in the
convention just like eyes me directly
and I'm like okay that's probably a fan
so I'm waiting for him to come over he
comes over to me and has the biggest
[__] happy face and he just goes oh
my God I love you
mean while God is standing for
just being like
this weird thing that happens when you
show your face a lot online where people
recognize you and they can they can
recognize you but they can never tell
you like where they recognize you from
yeah yeah and that one's always the
weird one but I've also heard that I I
started doing this because I heard some
other people were doing this too where
someone be like I'm a huge fan and then
you'd you would proceed to go name one
of my videos or name something oh you're
a fan name five sea dog videos I was
like I was curious one time and I was
like oh yeah which one
and they name one of Joey's videos
what's scary about this is this is
probably actually really common and we
just never asked probably yeah yeah
because you've probably never asked
people and they'd probably be like I'm a
huge fan and they probably they pretty
just I mean it's it's listen I don't
need someone to justify being a huge fan
if you're gonna approach Conor you
better have your friends no but just
don't say I'm don't specifically say I
am a huge fan if you are not a huge fan
I'm not gonna ask most of the time like
yeah whatever and like I'd say like you
can't you only ever tell the weird
stories right because like like 99 of
people are certainly even I remember
like the first fan I ever met was still
one of the strangest interactions I had
I can't remember if I've told you this
because you guys are not this was like
very shortly after like my my face
reveal a guy came up to me and he was
like um super I watch Wolf and I was
like oh that is the name of my YouTube
channel I I I had no like flow where I
had no idea how to handle this
interaction and then he goes oh man I
love your videos and it kind of goes
just so you know I'm straight which
immediately I was like
and then he just goes and like he says
it's so casually he just goes but I'll
suck your dick
he said it in a way that was really just
like this is not a weird thing to say at
all right and so I I just kind of went
like
well good to know uh I'm cool but thank
you for watching my videos
I just like you have something like the
wildest stories of like some fans
considering you do like just like video
essays you know like I can like I've
seen obviously you know with some people
who show their face a lot and do kind of
like maybe content like ours where you
get like a relationship or like a
parasaur social relationship
um but you you just you just [__]
started talking about anime making like
cool interesting stuff and uh you have
some wild stories sometimes which is why
I was very surprised when you went to ax
this year you did not like you you just
went you just did like a meet and greet
in public it had been like three
pandemic since the last time I'd done
that and I thought like this will go
fine yeah and it was [__] not [__]
immediately and then immediately and
then it was a fire hazard immediate it
was I I felt so bad because I was like I
said but I think think the lesson there
is don't [__] do that yeah because I
remember like we had our wake-up call in
MCM uh oh yeah yeah because you never
want to like admit that you got to be
like no I need people to manage like yes
we don't need security yeah I don't need
like like I don't need security I don't
need people to manage my fans yeah like
I'm one of them you know you never want
to admit that you've gotten to the point
where you're like oh [__] this is uh
Beyond My Control now yeah and like I
think even on my way to that Meetup I
was like something doesn't feel right
here like this is this might be a bad
idea how many people showed up so it
like I I don't know because the first
one was shut down immediately I didn't
even get there and so then we had to
move it to a second place and people
started showing up and it wasn't even
that many people uh but like one of the
con workers were like what the [__] is
this and then I just moved and then had
to move to a third and like by that
point there weren't that many people
because it was just like I think I think
exactly yeah well it's just a treasure
hunt at that point yeah yeah I've
noticed you've been showing your face
more often as well
yeah I kind of just there's more you can
do and there's more jokes you can make
like sometimes I write a joke and I'm
like this will be funnier if you can see
my face yeah you know but um I think
part of that is just like I just
I like trying new [__] you know and I
like I like just kind of disrespectful
if I but if I don't do that I'll get
bored and I've always felt like the
biggest danger to my channel like it's
not it's not YouTube or it's it's not
like you know just weird [__] you can't
control it's me losing interest and so I
have to do my best to keep it
interesting for me which is why the
topics I do tend to kind of vary so much
yeah it's that fear of like getting into
a routine right that's like that's why I
stopped making the why you should watch
videos that I used to make because I was
like it got to a point where it felt
like I could pull some levers and [__]
out a video and I hated that you know
what I mean everything's gonna be a
struggle yeah yeah if I'm not in some
amount of pain I'm not doing it right